[Music]
it's time for roses and rose a hey
everybody we're here to talk about
Corinne I mean The Bachelor I mean : I
don't mind it she keeps things
interesting long peace and victory The
Bachelor drinking game that you should
not play because it would be very
unhealthy for this episode of roses and
Rose a is to drink every time someone
obsesses about Corinne
if you like Sarna and like that's why
we're all intimidated ah yes I want to
stop and Corinne is all like why are
challenged aerosols Leslie it's a valid
question why you so obsessed with me
everybody spent this episode of The
Bachelor confronting current need to
pull together making both threats about
how they were going to leave if Corinne
stay Nate definitely runs the risk of
losing some other girls in the house if
currency is tonight cut to the rose
ceremony and port Corinne had something
in her eye for a really long time I'm
going to try to drink for the entirety
of the time the Corinne was fixing her
eyes
oh my god everybody is wondering why is
make into Corinne they're like if you're
looking for a girl or if you looking for
a woman just confused if he is looking
for a woman or a girl and I say some
people are in the words of Britney
Spears
[Music]
I get along
yeah and that's Corinne let her do her
thing everybody Corinne had so many
brilliant moments on this episode she
invented spot tacos
aka Paco's I want to be in a spa being
sent a nice taco she made the most
relevant and dead-on observations about
the group date in Milwaukee Wisconsin
when they told me up to shovel poop I
was like why what and when the ladies
calls her privileged she turned it
around and gave some grade-a shade we're
all so privileged and honored to be here
yes cheers to Corinne we head over to
Nick's hometown of Milwaukee Wisconsin I
have never seen a group of people so
excited to go to Milwaukee Wisconsin and
there are so many cool things to do in
Milwaukee you can feed the duck you can
eat a cookie you can shovel poop also on
this episode Corinne reveals who her
mentors are I now Michael Jordan's of
Nass Abraham Lincoln's Ignace diverse
and excellent choices and Corinne
revealed the title of her future
autobiography Oh horn house you gotta
peel the layers back and then now is
this luxury yellow corn
cheers to Corinne New York Times best
seller list I don't have much left and
I'm getting nervous so what else
happened in the episode other than
Corinne it's hard to remember Danielle
got a one-on-one date I love Danielle
still you guys she's amazing hair I got
to keep giving Nick credit I do think
he's giving each of the women some good
quality time with him and he's also
giving Corinne compliments for
compliments of deserve so much pain for
me and I'm very mature me everything
culminated in a conflict between Corinne
and Taylor Taylor is a mental health
counselor and I'm not entirely sure it's
a good idea for her professionally to
say things like this
yeah make people sure that they're not
ready to hear and again I don't Corinne
said a lot of solid intellectual things
tonight but there were a few times when
she faltered and we need to literally
punch her in the face that Rosie is two
weeks old I'm not picky
apparently Corinne or Taylor are going
to go home next week Corinne and Taylor
aren't done yet
Brynn is a manipulative [ __ ] and one of
them won't survive the week so who do
you guys think it should be let me know
over on Twitter and of course make sure
to subscribe PC on YouTube for more
roses and Rose a debauchery like if on
Facebook where we recap the bachelor
every Tuesday and follow me on Twitter
Instagram etc if you want to live with
me during the show I have not eaten
alone today
but I did drink a lot of Rosie and
that's the title my autobiography
[Music]
you